Вибори президента стали неабияким джерелом
натхнення для авторів мемів. Перед першим туром
українці висміювали пенсіонерів, які голосують за гречку;
намагалися іронізувати з оголених дівчат і голосів за солодке.
Перед другим туром однією з тем мемів стали
дебати кандидатів у президенти.
Зеленський просить Порошенка назвати три головні слова,
а Порошенко йому відповідає, що, мовляв, головне - не перемога.
Розробник стартапу мемів  -  20-річний Микита Шевченко -
не приховує свого задоволення від того, як українці
вміють посміятися з політиків.
Не менш задоволений чоловік і перемогою Володимира Зеленського.
Микита Шевченко на цих виборах голосував уперше.
Він при виборі свого президента керувався тим, що
не хоче, як він каже, "червоних директорів
або людей із СРСР при владі ".
- Разом із Зеленським у нас значно більше шансів
отримати реальні покарання в антикорупційній галузі.
Я вважаю, що він також може нарешті запустити економіку,
створивши нульові декларації для бізнесу.
19-річна студентка факультету політології
Києво-Могилянської академії Ірина Засимович теж
голосувала вперше. І дуже боялася,  що молодь
не прийде на вибори, адже у програмах
38-ми кандидатів у першому турі було замало планів
про відстоювання інтересів молоді. Ірина 31 березня
голосувала  в Україні, а потім поїхала в Німеччину
за програмою обміну і спостерігала звідти за перебігом кампанії.
Те, що переміг не її кандидат, а Володимир Зеленський,
дівчину засмутило.
- Він взяв людей обіцянками про нове обличчя,
про нову політичну стратегію.
Але, якщо чесно, аналізуючи його політичну
стратегію так звану,
там немає ніякого конструктиву.
Там лише одні якісь
голосні заяви. І я не дуже впевнена,
що він буде достойно виглядати на міжнародній арені.
Проте Ірина не вбачає "жодної катастрофи " в тому,
що Зеленський  – "не людина системи". Каже, що
Україна вже має такий досвід із мером столиці -
боксером Віталієм Кличком.
Інша студентка Києво-Могилянської академії -
факультету політології, 20-річна Діана Клим'юк із Коломиї, -
вважає, що "несистемність" Зеленського
збалансує його команда. На думку Діани,
перші півроку новообраний президент
може припуститися багатьох помилок.
Але дівчина впевнена, що Зеленський
намагатиметься довести свою спроможність,
а більшість "страшилок ", що розповсюджують
про Володимира Зеленського, можуть і не справдитися.
- Зеленський проросійський?
А чому Порошенко не проросійський?
Де цьому докази? З чого ви взяли, що якщо він там,
припустимо, розмовляє російською мовою,
значить, він обов'язково "за русский мир "?
Побоювань як таких... Я буду дивитися по ситуації
і пробувати
бути більш "флексібл ".
Жодного проросійського вектору -
вимога до нового президента 21-річного
Владислава Олюніна. Студент деревообробного  училища в Києві
очікує від нового головнокомандувача
передусім повернення втрачених територій.
- Щоб упродовж цих 5 років Україна була у своєму повному складі.
Територіально. Щоб Крим був український,
Донбас був українським і війни на території України не було.
А ще Владислав вимагає від  новообраного
президента реальної боротьби з корупцією, аби
на наступних виборах не з'являлися політики
з репутацією корупціонерів.
Микита дещо хвилюється, щоб нова
президентська команда не зупинила реформу медицини та освіти.
Ірина хотіла б мати більше впевненості, що
Володимир Зеленський не буде слабким
на зовнішній політичній арені.
Діана очікує від президента Зеленського якихось дій,
аби молодь мала гідну зарплату і не їхала за кордон.
Усі ці молоді українці обирали президента вперше.
І хоча не всі голосували за Зеленського,
вони сподіваються, що Україна не змінить
свого курсу на євроатлантичну інтеграцію
і що президент не повторить помилку попередника,
який не хотів, на їхню думку, чути голос
громадських активістів.